un diamant taillé à face est serti par
l'indre c'est ainsi que balzac décrira
le château d'azay-le-rideau un château
étroitement lié à l'indre l'indre qui
compte beaucoup de moulins mais aussi
d'autres châteaux je vous propose tout
de suite de découvrir le château de
villette qui marie effectivement la
rivière avec son architecture
traversé par l'indre l'histoire du
château de l'isle est étroitement liée à
la rivière en plus de fournir du poisson
dès le moyen-âge l'indre a été utilisé
pour sa force motrice
à l'origine il y avait un moulin qu'on
aperçoit derrière nous qu'il y avait
deux roues qui ont disparu ou qu'on sait
grâce au cadastre napoléonien qu'elle
était bien là au gré des péripéties de
la vie du château de l'isle est la
rivière l'indre c'est toujours invité
dans le paysage c'était différent on
avait l'inde qui faisait le tour du
château
il y avait des douves qui ont été
comblés au 19e siècle
un propriétaire nommé dupuis a tronqué
les tours rogner les lucarnes et combler
les douves mais à l'origine
lille est donc petite île ça portait
bien son nom le château avait les pieds
dans l'eau
[Musique]
quand on va un peu plus loin sur londres
c'est très calme très paisible donc
c'est très agréable juste poser les
rames et de se laisser porter par le
courant avec ce tout la nature autour
les oiseaux enfin voila c'est très
agréable les gens adorent ça c'est très
politique
nouvel horizon le toit du château
c'est la nature concernant mon
privilégié que tous les châteaux non pas
forcément
donc à un moment de se réunir en famille
d'être seul un petit peu sur la barque
et devoirs du coup le château d'un peu
plus fins avoir un point de vue un peu
plus particulier un peu plus unique que
juste une balade dans les parcs c'est
vraiment quelque chose de particulier et
d'unique à lille est quand le niveau de
l'indre le permet les visiteurs peuvent
parcourir la rivière embarque à travers
le parc du château un parc arboré et
irriguée par lot de l'indre
[Musique]
les habitants des lettres vivent
toujours au gré des fluctuations de son
niveau nous qu'en ce moment en été elle
est verte clair et c'est donc très
agréable de s'y promener en barque
le patrimoine architectural d'un château
renaissance est indissociable du
patrimoine naturel de l'eau qui lui
offre un miroir toujours fluctuante
on se retrouve sur la façade est du
château d'azay-le-rideau devant l'indre
qui sert de miroir au château avec
geneviève gil pas vous avez été
longtemps guidé vous êtes beaucoup
intéressé à la documentation sur ce
château d'azay-le-rideau le lien avec
l'indre il commence très tôt dès la
construction du château puisque en fait
ici on est sur une île et le la rivière
servait de défense naturelle de douves à
l'époque féodale c'était quoi les
fonctions de la rivière avec le château
fait déjà une fonction défensive puisque
les douves et était était là et puis
aussi une fonction nourricière puisque
au château dans les textes du moyen âge
on voit qu'il ya des gars douar des
gardois à poissons et la paix c'était un
endroit réservé aux seigneurs sith un
des droits seigneuriaux donc lui seul
avait le droit ou ses sbires d'aller
pêcher dans la dans l'indre alors plus
tard vers le dix septième si j'ai bien
compris il ya une fonction ornementale
qui est donnée à l'eau ça ça arrive d'où
cette idée d'utiliser l'eau dans la
décoration
ça vient du du seigneur du dudit de
l'époque henri françois de masse et qui
était très bien en cours qui avait vécu
à versailles et qui ont appelé monsieur
l'impertinent il avait été renvoyé dans
ses foyers par par le roi il fallait
bien qu'ils s'occupent donc ici à zé et
larmes et la transformer les douves
c'est à dire la rivière naturel en
douves maçonné et là par exemple on voit
encore un bras de
de la douve qu'il a acquise à maçonner
tout autour de la basse cour
c'était important lot la présence de
l'eau à cette époque là d'une manière
ornementale oui et d'ailleurs louis xiii
est passé ici en mois de juin ces 119 et
il a fait un petit tour de barque sur le
sur la rivière d'indre il a bu aussi du
sirop de cerise à d importants
aujourd'hui la rivière le lien entre le
château la rivière c'est encore
important il ya eu des nouvelles
transformations plus contemporaine c'est
là c'est l'image du château d'azay c'est
celle au c'est lola l'image du miroir le
château se reflétant dans l'eau
jusqu'aux jusqu'en 1959 tout autour du
château les y avait une bande de terre
en terrasse qui a été enlevé et du coup
le château se reflète complètement dans
l'eau sur cette façade sud
un patrimoine qui se mélangent à l'eau
et qui rend aussi d' endroit frais et
agréable en cette période estivale